hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar implementation of helical vector
pylori stool antigen testing in a large
metropolitan center a prospective
comparative diagnostic trial i am
michelle ashton of laberd's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
laberd's and brought to you by dia
Sauron to learn more about our sponsor
please visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor you
want anytime you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send our speaker will answer your
questions via email following this
webinar if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speaker dr. Dylan Pillai
the professor of pathology and
Laboratory Medicine at the University of
Calgary for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr. Pillai you
may now begin your presentation
ok thanks Michelle my name is dr. Dylan
Pillai I'm a medical microbiologist at
the University of Calgary and today I'm
going to talk to you about the
implementation of Helicobacter pylori
stool antigen testing in a large
metropolitan center a prospective
comparative diagnostic trial so the
objectives I have for today are to
firstly gain understanding of h pylori
test
options ii described challenges and
benefits of utilizing h pylori stool
engine testing and finally demonstrate
how to effectively consult key clinical
stakeholders in the implementation of
this testing I have one disclosure I
have received unrestricted educational
grants from Basara so let's get right
into it he let go back to pylori or h
pylori is a gram-negative spiral-shaped
bacterium that infects up to 45% of the
global population especially in
developing countries most of these
infected individuals are actually
asymptomatic up to 90%
however the bacteria can cause chronic
active gastritis peptic ulcer disease
and gastric adenocarcinoma as well as
mucosa associated lymphoid tissue
lymphoma oma lymphoma these are
cancerous conditions eradicating the
bacterial infection cures the gastritis
and can prevent some of these long term
complications the risk factors related
to H pylori infection include crowded
living conditions poor sanitation and
low set socioeconomic status and this is
perhaps why it is so prevalent in
developing countries so where does H
pylori or helical bacter sit in the
family tree as you can see here by the
arrow on the right hand side h pylori is
nestled here amongst all the
Helicobacter genus most of which are non
pathogenic to humans however certain
species such as Helicobacter saniti have
been associated with bacterial infection
of the bloodstream in immunocompromised
individuals and as you can see at the
bottom of the tree Helicobacter is
closely related to another organism
capital vector which we know well causes
diarrheal infections one of the classic
features of Helicobacter as a genus and
- pylori is the production of urease so
uris production is indicated here by
this bright pink fuchsia color you can
see in the tube marked B and this
particular agar Christensen's urea
results in a pink color when urease
breaks down or breath production breaks
down urea for the production of ammonia
and carbon dioxide which alkalinize is
the media and causes this color change
so let's going back to Helicobacter
pylori ruling out h pylori is required
for the diagnosis of functional
dyspepsia screening tools with
non-invasive methods such as the urea
breath test and stool antigen testing is
preferred where the incidence of gastric
complications are low more severe
disease requires invasive testing via an
endoscopic evaluation and ultimately
biopsy gastric cancer is actually the
third most common cause of cancer
mortality with over 700 thousand deaths
globally in 2012 and therefore you can
imagine that screening and erratic in
age burglary as one of the causes is
essential so peptic ulcer disease is the
classic presentation of Helicobacter
pylori and while I said that most
patients are asymptomatic
some patients experience symptoms like
dyspepsia or fullness or upper abdominal
pain and in some cases as I mentioned
this can develop further into new plays
your cancer these ulcers as you can see
by this cartoon or essentially a
breakdown of that mucosal wall that
protects the stomach and in some cases
the duodenum as well here you can see
example of a gastric ulcer ulcer and
Edoardo ulster and on the right hand
side of this slide we can see again a
cartoon of what the bacteria essentially
does it adheres to the mucosal mucosa in
the ulcer and there's a gene called the
cytotoxic associated gene or CAG a which
is thought to be oncogenic
and of course as I mentioned below the
classic feature of this organism is the
breakdown of urea used by the enzyme
urease for the production of ammonia
carbon dioxide an important feature of h
pylori is the fact that it has become
drug resistant to the antibiotics that
we currently use to treat h pylori this
slide shows that for example in the
United States there is more than 15%
resistance to clarithromycin for
first-line treatment for h pylori and in
the case of Canada you can see that over
40% of isolates that have been tested
are resistant to clarithromycin and over
30% on the y-axis are resistant to
metronidazole these are both very
important drugs and indeed resistance H
pylori has been deemed by the World
Health Organization to be a priority -
or high need for new antibiotics in line
with organisms like vancomycin-resistant
enterococci cuts and
methicillin-resistant Staph aureus so as
you can see h pylori drug resistance is
a major problem in our emerging issue so
what are the diagnostic tests that we
use to detect h pylori and this table
essentially breaks it down into non
invasive methods and invasive methods
under non invasive methods at the top we
have serology while serology is widely
available and inexpensive the positive
result may actually be reflect previous
infection and not current infection so
that's not very useful to the screening
of h pylori in a population where there
is a high prevalence for example because
it may indeed because it may essentially
be describing previous infection the
urea breath test has good sensitivity
and specificity over 95% with high
negative and positive predictive value
this is a useful test for screening
however false negative results
are possible when the patient is on
proton pump inhibitors for example and
there are some difficulties in
performing this test in certain
individuals for example young children
who can't comply with the instructions
moving down stool antigen test again a
very highly sensitive and specific test
with good positive and negative
predictive values with the perhaps the
caveat that here a disadvantage is that
some patients may not like to collect
stool and provide stool and and that may
be an issue invasive tests as mentioned
before include biopsy coupled with
histology or a rapid urease test both of
which can be performed on the biopsy
material in some instances culture is
required as seen at the bottom because
culture enables the detection of
antibiotic susceptibility testing which
may be important in patients who fail
eradication treatment so what's the gold
standard for testing currently in the
literature - typically a composite of
biopsy findings rapid ureas tests and/or
culture can be used as a gold standard
with no single test being really
conclusive and in many studies when two
of these three tests are positive
they're considered to be a goal stone
positive so that's something that's
seeking that quite often in the
literature this is what a biopsy stain
typically looks like and in the bottom
right-hand panel you can see an
immunohistochemical stain of the gastric
material in the biopsy with the red hue
identifying areas that are infected with
the helical back to pylori organism the
other panels represent other stains that
can be used such as hematoxylin and
eosin and panel a giemsa and a warrant
story silver stain and panel see the
rapid ureas test is an indirect test of
h pylori based on the presence of urease
in the gastric mucosa it does require
biopsy material and it has the advantage
of a serology in that it only detects
the presence of an active infection
however it is an invasive test requiring
endoscopy the test requires a sample of
the mucosa or mucous that is added to
the tube or gel
and that's how the detection of the
urease enzyme as I've mentioned which is
classic for Helicobacter in the next
slide here I show some examples of three
popular commercial rapid here--yes tests
that are used including the Clos test
and two other tests the basis of this
test again is the breakdown of urea into
ammonia and carbon dioxide which
alkalizes the media and produces this
positive in Kish or a fuchsia color here
you can see in the cloud test another
screening test that's used that's not
invasive is the h pylori urea breath
test so for this test patient
preparation is required
firstly a patient cannot be on
antibiotics for up to four weeks no use
of bismuth or pepto-bismol for example
for two weeks and the patient should be
off of proton pump inhibitors for 14
days and no antacids or antihistamines
for 24 hours additionally the patient
should not have eaten drunk or smoked
anything in the last four hours the
patient is asked to drink a solution
containing the labelled urea and wait
approximately an hour each perlier is h
pylori breaks down the label of urea
into ammonia and carbon dioxide which is
labeled and the patient breathe isn't
breathed into a tube where the label
carbon dioxide is measured in the
exhaled air as you can imagine these
instructions are difficult to follow for
young patients under six years of age or
elderly patients with difficulties again
complying with the method here h pylori
stool antigen testing is another
screening method that's available and
here again there are patient preparation
steps four weeks of no antibiotics no
bismuth products for two weeks and no
proton pump inhibitors for the same
amount of time the preparation is
simpler however because the patient
essentially takes home a collection
container and instructions from the
doctor's office and collects the stool
samples
and delivers it to the lab as soon as
possible ideally within eight hours or
if there are any delays the sample would
have to be refrigerated and brought in
within 72 hours the test is an enzyme
immunoassay that detects antigens in the
stool and some patients may not be
comfortable handling and storing their
own stool however there is a no
requirement for preparation as with the
urea breath test
so comparing side by side your your
breath test in the stool antigen test
you can see the B your breath test does
require an appointment with certain
patient preparation steps that are
required such as fasting there is a
one-hour lab visit that is required for
the earlier breath test whereas its
dimension test essentially the sample
can be collected at home and we're
dealing here with a breath sample versus
stool samples and there's this non
suitability for patients under six years
of age for the urea breath test whereas
the stool antigen test essentially can
be performed for all patients who can
provide a stool sample the performance
characteristics are the same however a
false positives can occur with certain
bacteria such as Pseudomonas or
Neisseria for the rear breath test and
false negatives with low level infection
or bleeding the stool and gene test and
in our setting we have noticed a
difference in cost 20 in this cost
includes labor and reagents for testing
but does not include test administration
for the unity one note about children
this publication in 2003 compared the
urea breath tests with the stool antigen
test for the diagnosis of h pylori and
children and their conclusion was
essentially that the sensitivity and the
specificity as well as the positive and
negative predictive values were
identical essentially or similar between
the urea breath test and the stool
antigen test the authors conclude that
both tests are appropriate for
diagnosing h pylori infection in
children however as noted with children
under 6 years of age compliance with the
your breath test is not possible
it's important to note that the euro
breath does is more resource intensive
and what I mean by this is that
appointments are required where the
patient must come into a service center
or a laboratory facility and require a
staff time for the administration of the
test the test also may require time away
from work for patients and this may be
potentially disadvantage to low
socio-economic groups where the
prevalence of HP Laurie infection is in
fact high and the disadvantage
essentially is that these patients have
to take time away from work whereas with
the stool antigen test the patient can
provide these tools sample when it's
convenient for them so who should be
screened if we look at low prevalence
settings like the United States and
Canada essentially any patients that are
symptomatic with dyspepsia can be
screened with non invasive methods
however high-risk patients those who are
older with high family risk factors or
from an area with high rates of gastric
cancer or patients with the red flag
symptoms such as bleeding should be
subject to endoscopy and more invasive
testing so in our Center we conducted a
prospective diagnostic trial comparing
the ubt to the stool antigen test and
the motivation for this was that we had
more than 50 day waiting periods for
their breath tests due to a lack of
patient service at mr. administrate the
study was conducted in Calgary in
Alberta a city of approximately 1.3
million people with a centralized
laboratory system in a total of 150
patients were agreed to undergo urea
breath tests and consented to provide a
stool specimen simultaneously for stool
antigen test so these patients
essentially volunteer consented and
volunteered to provide this tool antigen
test while undergoing a ub t so that we
could compare them side-by-side
two essays here in question that were
used were the ubt kit the heli kit as
well as the dinosaurian liaison excel h
pylori stool antigen monoclonal
chemiluminescent masse so the stool
hydrogen test was performed on and
unpreserved stool and run on a high
throughput and detection system the
system as I mentioned is the liaison si
the liaison h pylori stool action CLIA
test which uses a monoclonal antibody
and the result is available within 24
hours of a stool collection.this the
antibody is a monoclonal which is
important and that's it that's directed
at the flagella and a protein which
forms part of the flagella of the
bacterium
so this is essentially how the test is
run you can see on the left hand side
there's a specimen preparation stool
extraction device that's used to collect
or to inoculate the stool specimen and
in the center we see the liaison Excel
analyzer this is the chemiluminescent
analysis that's performed and there's 35
minutes to the first results to fully
automate a testing solution and stool as
well as serum samples can be run
together on this instrument so there any
other tests that are performed and the
results are qualitative and are produce
results that are roughly 170 results per
hour in our own experience we have a
found it important that there be
training on sampling technique and that
is essential in order to inoculate the
correct amount of stool into the system
and that instrument calibration and
decontamination are essential from time
to time in order to ensure that the
results and the values obtained are
consistent throughout the year an
important note here about specimen
stability as I mentioned in an earlier
slide SAP
should be ideally refrigerated between
two to eight degrees Celsius for up to
72 hours if the sample cannot be tested
within that semi two hours storage
samples can be frozen at minus twenty
and then tested after that the sample
extract is stable up to eight hours at
room temperature 72 hours refrigerated
up to 12 weeks frozen and generally
freeze thaw cycles obviously of the
sample extract and definitely of the
stool sample are discouraged the urea
breath tests in this study was the hell
akkada
a breath test that was performed to
detect h pylori bacteria it's a
non-invasive non radioactive method and
uses a convenient breath test kit for
the diagnosis and it's safe to be used
on children over the age of six so here
are the results of the trial as I
mentioned 150 patients volunteered to
provide both urea breath test and stool
antigen test and essentially 148 out of
150 patients had identical results
either positive or negative for the
stool for h pylori so this room using
the urea breath tests as a gold standard
in this particular case the sensitivity
of the stool antigen test was 96.3% the
specificity of 100% which leads to a
positive predictive value of 100 and a
negative 2 2 valium 99.2% the disease
prevalence or the positivity rate in
this particular study was 18 percent one
of the two discrepant that was ubt
positive but stool engine test negative
resolved after repeat testing on the
stool antigen so this leads to about a
98 to 99 percent agreement between the
two tests we did look at in the trial
the use of specific antibiotics for the
treatment of h pylori 38 out of 130
patients where we had antibiotic
information had received an antibiotic
associated with HIV
the preceding 12 months however some of
those antibiotics may be linked to other
disease states such as ear infections or
pneumonia we can't be 100% sure there
was a related to H pylori and out of the
38 patients that had received those
antibiotics 37 had kokorin results
between the ubt and the stool antigen
test of note 6 out of 130 or 4.6 percent
had received a specific combination anti
H by Laurie treatment and all of these 6
out of 6 had concordant results between
the two which was encouraging that the
stool antigen test and the ub t-test
provide kokorin results post treatment
to demonstrate a successful eradication
which is done routinely so as a result
of this study implementation was
discussed and we consulted key
stakeholders in the arena
gastroenterologist our clinical
chemistry colleagues as well as our
Medical Microbiology colleagues we
looked at the literature and guidelines
that were available and as I said the
major motivator to change testing was
the wait times which were currently
greater than 50 days due to lack of
space cost as well was noted as a major
consideration in our single-payer model
with a fixed budget for testing so in
scanning the environment for the
literature evaluating ub t as well as
stool antigen test we noted this
important study in 2009 from barcelona
here are patients with greater than or
to positive test results were considered
to be true positives and the studies
that were done on these patients
included the rapid urea test
histological examination that urea
breath test and the stool antigen test
these authors concluded that the
sensitivities and specificities of
ninety percent and ninety three percent
for the stool test and 90 percent of
sensitivity and specification for the
urea breath test ultimately the authors
concluded that the stool insertion test
and urea breath tests were essentially
equivalent
invasive options another study published
out of Bologna Italy with the specific
stool antigen test used in our study
looked at therapeutic monitoring
compared against two lantian tests to
your breath test and they found that the
agreement was in 58 total tests done
there was essential agreement of
approximately 98.3% between the ubt and
the stool antigen test again encouraging
that these tests perform in an
equivalent manner so what did the major
guidelines on testing say about stool
antigen testing versus your breath
testing for each part Laura infection
firstly the Maastricht for Florence
consensus report concluded here in red
that the diagnostic accuracy of the
stool antigen test is equivalent to the
urea breath test if a validated
laboratory based monoclonal test is used
turning to the United States the 2018
Houston consensus conference recommends
that only tests that evaluate for active
infection such as the urea breath test
the stool antigen test or histology are
used for post treatment confirmation of
eradication and this was great winning
evidence and closer to home the Canadian
Agency for drugs and technologies
concluded that the EIA based and ICA
based tests using monoclonal antibodies
were comparable with endoscopy and/or
the ureter best tests determine the
results of h pylori eradication therapy
so we see close alignment of major
guidelines on the use of the stool under
test and the urea breath test for
screening we turn to laboratories with
similar patient populations and similar
volumes and here at the Mayo Clinic we
see circled in red that for patients
without red flag symptoms between the
ages of 3 to 54 the either the urea
breath test or this two NHS are used to
screen for h pylori
so what conclusions can we draw based on
our own study and the literature as well
as guidelines and some of our peer
laboratories across North America
essentially we concluded that based on
our data of 98.7 percent equivalence
between the two test theory breath tests
to run tests and 99.2% negative
predictive value and 100 percent
positive predictive value the
implementation of stool antigen tests in
our region was recommended especially in
view of the wait times that were
required to obtain your FS furthermore
revised algorithm was required in order
to advocate for the stool Angelyn tests
to improve the access and achieve
satisfactory clinical outcomes so the
current algorithm in our particular
region here in Calgary was that if there
is suspected dyspepsia here at the top
without alarm features such as GI
bleeding or progressive dysphasia
persistent vomiting then the medic and
medication review would be offered if
there was no offending medication such
as non-steroidal anti-inflammatories
which can cause peptic ulcers then
baseline investigations are done such as
a CBC ferritin celiac serology liver
function tests as well as an ultrasound
and then moving further down if these
all were normal the current algorithm
required the ID or breath test however
with the advent of our study and further
review of the literature this was
changed to the stool antigen test to
improve access however if the request
for ubt were made these were triage by
the microbiologist on call and the UB T
is still permitted if this dual action
was negative three times or if the
patient was unable to provide a stool
for whatever reason in the correct
condition or if the result of the
students test was equivocal the UB T was
still available so what actually
happened here are some of the post
implementation data from our own region
you can see in the red line that the
volumes of the stool of the
test went down as we changed our forms
to accommodate the stool antigen test
and the stool androgen tests volumes
increased from a baseline of less than
100 up to now si state of close to 2500
tests per month so the required of the
changes in the screening algorithms went
into effect and had the requisite impact
which was to switch the need from the
arrest test to the stringent test in
order to improve access and the wait
times for h pylori testing did go down
as expected from an average of 50 days
down to essentially within 24 hours or
as soon as a stool sample could be
provided so and this was an important
impact that we wanted to measure another
important impact was the cost to the
laboratory so these were the monthly
savings pre and post-implementation of
the age whether is to imagine tests so
as you can see as the h pylori volumes
hit a steady state of close to 2300 to
2500 the EBT volumes decreased in those
cases that still required it we accrued
monthly savings of close to 11,000
dollars in this particular setting and
this only includes reagents and labor
does not include cost outside of the
laboratory
so in summary h pylori is to any testing
provides in our setting equivalent
results to the rear breath test in our
population tested and the replacement of
the rear breath test by the stool engine
tests as the primary screening modality
was driven essentially by our switch in
the algorithm and our need to improve
wait times and reduce costs and these
were achieved in our setting early
utilization data suggests interestingly
that by switching through the stool
antigen test there has been improved
access to low-income areas of the city
where the prevalence of HP Laurie is
high
there were difficulties presumably in
accessing the urea breath test we
believe that the urea ëthis is still
warranted where this tool engine tests
are equivocal or patients are not
willing to provide stool samples or as
mentioned there are persistent symptoms
in spite of negatives to imagine tests
and an endoscopy hasn't yet been
performed further evaluation of the
stool and the test is ongoing in post
treatment situations and this may be
important to gather important
information about eradication so with
that I conclude my talk I thank you for
your attention and goodbye
thank you dr. Pillai for your
informative presentation as a reminder
our speaker will follow up with any
questions you have submitted via email
following the webinar we would also like
to thank lab roots and our sponsor dia
Sauron for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand moderates will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's event until next time
goodbye